i want to know what you guys want to
hear a rap about so every person here
think of a word or a topic or a phrase
you'd like to rap about
sea sponges okay i guess that counts as
coral not animals so i will accept it
yeah
and wait what did you say
[Music]
the fifth ocean we did we did just add
that didn't we cool and that feels
pretty nice cool so sea sponge is in
we've got a new ocean guys was it the
sixth someone over there is getting
getting confused everyone else is like
wait there's more than two oceans what
the [ __ ] going on
there's the atlantic there's the pacific
and uh okay cool so let's come to this
over here we've got sea sponges in the
new southern ocean what do you guys want
to wrap up
one second you're not in that wait sorry
someone is saying sponge spongebob and
anal which is worrying me
what is it from down here
is it spongebob and anal is that what it
was okay cool
spongebob is that literally a child over
there that was
spongebob yes in my country is called
spongebob square trousers um
okay so front segment of the room on
this level what would you like a rap
about
it
just tony soprano okay cool
imagine if he'd said a character of any
other nationality and you then shouted
out something that sounded like that
okay cool so tony soprano and a guy
going gabagool
i know he says i've seen the show okay
middle middle segment of the room what
do you wanna rap about
taco bell okay
that's pretty popular with a large
amount of the room i imagine there'll be
quite a long queue at the bathrooms
after this show
back of the room what would you like a
rap about
[Music]
there were so many of you but what was
the one that ended with factory career
oh charlie's factory career oh wait you
oh [ __ ] yeah
cool
okay
um so just to recap guys we have sea
sponges in the southern ocean spongebob
anal
tony soprano charlie's factory career
and what was our other one that we had
over there taco bell of course um
red and jeremy
just um are we able to like mix it up
and do a kind of different beat i know
that you that we did a b in the earlier
show but i kind of wanted to keep it a
bit more like chill and can you like is
that doable
like is i don't have the energy to keep
it like a hundred all the time so let's
uh
yeah this feels good i feel like i
should be wearing a tuxedo
[Applause]
okay
so freestyle for those of you that don't
know it's made up it's not written it's
not prepared it's not rehearsed and it
will not be as bad as you're expecting a
privately educated middle-class white
british boy to be let's do this nice
i'm in the ocean the water i'm taking
the plunge or a report about the shorts
and i'm checking out the sponge when i'm
down there i got the tank upon my back i
love the sponge i can see it in the
volcanic crack cause they kind of
cluster around the little geothermal
vents i was in the southern ocean and
i'm making sense before it didn't exist
but then they had it on the globe the
little ocean all of you all better know
i'll be off the coast of india maybe
south africa take a sponge from there
i'm gonna have a bath with you do it
like a loofah scraping off i start this
picking up the sponge like i'm updating
a starfish i say yeah i got em i'm gonna
take the cartoon one from bikini bottom
he's living in the pineapple under the
sea and likes that intercourse anally
and it's painful for him yeah he gonna
catch this take a fat rod in the ass
from patrick he's like yo do me let the
octopus watch wank cough yeah masturbate
with us and it's fine the spongebob orgy
you see the meme on lines we adore these
and that's okay it's going well after
anal sex you need to clean it up like a
meal out a taco bell you feel that the
chili going through so many enchiladas i
should have proved i've got a little
crispy thing getting that chalupa i take
it right home and it just shoots through
you it's difficult you gotta take a
little bit of water to rehydrate i know
i should order in advance online but
always forget but takes like 10 minutes
what's with that [ __ ] how are they so
quick there with my order tony soprano
what's he want when he orders at his
little deli at his little sub place he
just shouts gabba ghoul from his dumb
face and how did the end of the show
ever end yeah it was just black out my
friend you didn't know whether he got
shot or survived spoiler if you didn't
make it past season five now the last
coming year charming to me at the comedy
show front i'm seeing charlie looking at
the guy while i rap do your mind if i
lean forward borrow your cap and rock it
out like this yeah i don't mean to
impinge there hard to tell under the
lights but charlie's ginger wearing a
raglan shirt is two colors you're
looking kind of similar are these two
brothers i don't know but let me pop the
cap right back i know you got an urge
when you were a young lad like i'll tell
you what yo actually i wanna go work out
in the factory no fear
charlie getting that career rise from
the factory floor he's moving here used
to be a supervisor but he's rising up
the ladder nobody's like charlie no one
can do it bada under factory let me get
a lot of love and know hey what's the
factory make charlie obviously chocolate
that's the pun on the road our book
that's a freestyle flow and this [ __ ]
was off the hook
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]